good morning it's Tuesday so hear the
heart ask people who donated to her
Kickstarter to show off their kitchens
because she might come cooking no yes
I'm not hungry you hungry I am too I was
lying before all right we should eat
some dinner so we're gonna cook dinner
and show off our kitchen for Hannah Hart
do you think we should start with a
drink
how about fresh-squeezed grapefruit
juice you know my grapefruit juice I'm
listening I'm into it let's try it
all right Henry what is the first step
in making grapefruit juice we have to
get that's correct too does cutting with
sharp knives in this family yeah that's
right who doesn't know it's you by the
way who's the better cook isn't daddy or
mommy yeah that's just not accurate
every great meal starts with a grape
juice you won't have a little bit of
grapefruit juice and then you want to
spike it thank you I recommend spiking
with water mmm - delicious how's yours
Sally so once you have your first
cocktail you're ready to start cooking
and in our house that means what's for
dinner
macaroni and cheese we decide of
whatever we can find in the fridge
everybody likes asparagus really it's
like the fruit of the sea but it's from
land hmm all right let's here we got
here now leftovers are always promising
but that appears to have kale so that's
out all right so we got asparagus mild
cheddar cheese celery blueberries sweet
potato fries mac and cheese and
tortillas this is gonna be great but
we're missing one thing
blueberry muffins okay step one feed
your kid at blueberry muffin because you
should have served him dinner like 30
minutes ago but you were screwing around
with grapefruit juice and you're gonna
want to heat 6 cups of water for your
macaroni and you know like regular
amount for your asparagus now Henry
experts will tell you to wait the water
is boiling but I am NOT cooking for
experts I'm cooking for a three-year-old
so you can really throw the asparagus in
it any time you want
protip put your iphone underneath the
washed asparagus you take the celery and
then you add like peanut butter and
raisins and then it's called ants on a
log no you don't want peanut butter on
it what are you a communist
yes you are that's a surprise but you
know what I'm just happy that you're
politically engaged at your age I think
that's great at this point you want to
start plating your freshly washed
blueberries this communist celery
meanwhile you get your asparagus started
and now is when you give up on the idea
of cheesy tortillas which let's face it
was a terrible idea in the first place
agreed put this weeped Enterprise in the
microwave for maximum sogginess which is
how Henry likes them and have a drink
because you're getting there
sour protip so the best way to know that
your asparagus is done is when you're
bored and you don't want to wait anymore
to eat it also don't forget to put your
macaroni on the wrong stovetop so that
it never actually boils take out the
asparagus that water is finally boiling
you don't want it al dente you want it
soggy you and I are on the same page
buddy yeah yeah soggy and cheesy once
your pastas good and cooked you take it
from there and you put it in the little
strainer thing oh this is where it can
all be wrong but it all went right then
you add your milk yes oh it just looks
delicious and at last you add in the
pasta then plate and enjoy so Hank and
Hannah that's how Henry and I make
dinner together here in Indianapolis
dftba
I'll see you on Friday you say dftba oh
it's pretty good